Well,
I actually am the founder of the founder
is a guy named Steve Hindi.
Uh,
who founded it with his,
uh,
his neighbor,
Tom Potter.
And Steve had been a reporter in the
Middle East.
Uh,
you know,
he knew all the major players over there
from Yasser Arafat too,
you know,
uh,
all the people that,
that,
that really were the main people on the
stage back in the seventies and
eighties.
And when he worked over in the Middle
East,
they often,
the journalists would make their own
beer when they were in station places
that didn't allow alcohol.
So through that he fell in love with
brewing,
came back to the United States and was
brewing with his neighbor who was a
banker and it was a commercial bank loan
officer and they got together and
started Brooklyn brewery in 1988.
Uh,
I came on in 1994 to build the new
brewery in Brooklyn and to expand from
the tube or beers that they had back
then to the 15 or 16 and a year that we
create right now.
Um,
so,
uh,
I've been with the brewery for 14 years
now.
No,
they're all kind of like,
you know,
my,
my children,
you know,
you guys like,
oh,
which is the,
which is your favorite child.
Um,
now some days you might actually have an
answer for that question and that would
be true,
I think of the beers as well.
But if you asked me in the middle of
winter,
you're going to get a completely
different answer than you're going to
get on a hot day in summer.
If you asked me on a boat,
you'll get a different answer than you
get in my house.
It really depends on what I'm having for
dinner.
So,
um,
I think of the beers as all having their
particular talents and it's just about
like what mood I man at any particular
time
voted to me more likely we fear or a
Pilsner,
cause I'm probably going to be having a
number of them.
I don't want anything,
uh,
you know,
two heavy.
Um,
but,
uh,
and I,
I like,
I like the sharp,
bitter flavor of,
uh,
of the pills and there,
so I'm probably gonna lean in that
direction.
Well,
it depends on before or after dinner,
before dinner or with dinner.
It's Brown Ale was after dinner,
then it's going to be our black
chocolates out.
Wow.
In my case,
it'll be a rooftop in Brooklyn.
Um,
but,
uh,
and I do have 800,
a big 800 square foot roof and a these
days it's totally been our,
uh,
Brooklyn local one,
which is,
uh,
you know,
the one that we're doing the bottle re
fermentation on,
you know,
it's 9%.
So you have to be careful about the
stairs as you go back down from the
roof.
But,
uh,
you know,
we,
we've been having a very good time with
that,
uh,
in the last year
Brooklyn lager because that's probably
why,
uh,
you know,
at least for us,
that's,
that's our,
that's our flagship.
Uh,
that's our flagship beer.
It's the beer that we're,
we're probably best known for.
And a,
and thankfully,
almost anywhere you go,
especially downtown in New York City,
you're going to see a Brooklyn lager.
And,
uh,
you know,
and,
uh,
we,
we still love it.
I think
it's a great beer.